Three-two-one
Meme review
-clap clap clap-
-clap-
Legend Johnny Dee finally did a cover
By Gucci Gang
we did it together
-Johnny raps Gucci Gang by Little Pump-
Better than Eminem
*chuckle*
Better than original!
For real.
People ask me all the time
"Felix, what is your favorite meal?"
"What is the snack that you eat before your videos to get you that edge?"
And I always say
Tide Pods
Tide Pods are...  delicious.
They are so tasty
Salt
Savory
Moist
Dry
All these
components just packed into a Tide Pod. It is so good
Now
They came out with a Hot Pocket Tide Pods and I gotta say
I'm not- this is not #sponcered but I wish because it is delicious
The crust of the Hot Pockets containing the savory of the Tide Pods it really hits your stomach in a way that I can't-
even begin to explain
It's not just me that love Tide Pods, of course. Squidward
another famous e-celeb, loves
loves Tide Pods
Even Spongebob loved Tide Pods. There's even Mexican style
-chuckles-
There's even Mexican style Tide Pods, which I haven't I haven't tried yet
But I can only imagine that you don't need it. You clearly don't need any other condiments in there cuz that's
That looks good by itself. He also got there Totino's pizza roll detergent those are
Sorta like an off-brand Tide Pods, but nevertheless still probably very
delicious!
"Give up your seats to someone carrying something more important"
That's right. If you see a pregnant lady carrying a Tide Pod, you need to let her sit and take your spot
"Excuse me, I didn't know you were pregnant with a Tide Pod. I am so sorry. Please have my seat"
Don't judge me, but Tide Pods are fuckin'
delicious and basically, I just ate
47 oF them
Damn, that's a lot of Tide Pods. I don't think I have ever eaten that many Tide Pods
People cooking Tide Pods
Just sharing. What is the best way to enjoy a Tide Pod?
"No more eating xanax in 2018 we eating tide pods from now on" That's right. Now if you don't get the joke
-chuckles-
Somehow it became a meme that you're supposed to eat Tide Pods
uh and eh
We have all these websites like "BuzzFeed" and "Mashable" saying
Don't. Don't eat Tide Pods. and I feel like I should say that too
but they're just so delicious.
Some people, some "haters" in the tide pod community says that it's
Toxic (scary music)
oo00ooOOo0o-
Or you could die
aaaAAAaaaAAaAAa
Clearly these people don't know the great word of the Tide Pods
And how delicious they are
Now the origin of this meme some people speculate is from "The Onion" supposed  two years ago
but recently got a lot of traction.
For whoever the fuck knows what reason. "I can't believe I have to say this but... please don't eat Tide Pods"
I guess you want them all for yourself, Mashable!
Don't think I'm onto your game
I'm even matching my outfit with Tide Pods. Step up your shit, Mashable
I bet you wish you were a Tide Pod cuz I wish that every night.
Please God, make me eh into Tide Pod
Someone some brave soul wrote to "Gushers", the candy brand, and asked hear me out
There was a fruit snack that looked like a laundry pod not any specific brand one because you know legality
But what if it looked like a laundry pod we all want to eat them so bad. Thanks for your time
I hope it takes off...
and they blocked her.
Disgusting. We also have Tide Pod-chan and probably the most beautiful
Being ever created in this universe. sorry Marzia
Tide Pod-chan wins every time. Tide Pod-chan. Here we have a furry account enjoying some
Tide Pod pizza.
Look at that! Wow! having a... having a great time. Look, uh...
*Tide Pods kick in*
That Looks so good!
I... I feel jealous *stutters* but at the same time, it's wonderful.
It's wonderful that people share their own recipes.
I feel sick. We even have famous chefs like Gordon Ramsay
Delicious. Finally some good effing food
I haven't been eating my whole life until I discovered Tide Pods. "When you're listening to someone speak and you can feel your  Tide Pod hit"
So, go forth.
Share the Tide Pod, the Great Wisdom . No longer
it would be a secret for the unknown. Share the Tide Pod with a friend, have a snack
have a Tide Pod
Tide Pod meme is a solid 8.1
I would say it could even get to a 10 if someone dies
I think someone needs to die for a meme to, to get to 10/10. You know what I mean?
(claps) next (claps) meme
(claps) please (claps)
Thank youuuuuu
You know we're gonna talk about Logan Paul memes everybody. They're fresh
They're hot and they're gonna burn out fast. "*seeing a dead man* Logan Paulers: Yo you alive?"
We have the Sayori hanging meme and Logan Paul
reacting to it. Horrible. Despicable. I can't believe he did this.
Literally anything hanging, Logan Paul just can't help himself. He has to react to it.
There's just too much clickbait on thumbnail. How could you do that Logan?
How could you do that? "Yoda watching sacred texts burn in The Last Jedi (2017, colorized)"
We have Logan Paul playing the famous game, The Forest.
Logan Paul reacting to po- poor Kermit. What even Kermit ever do Logan?
You don't have... Goddamnit! Will someone stop Logan? "When your friend asked if you want to hang out" (T R I G G E R E D)
That was good meme. Here's Logan Paul reacting to Spongebob hanging. Logan, please
"Understand that suicide is a real and big issue and use your platform to make awareness for it. Clickbait suicide for money and views"
Well done Logan Paul.
Someone pointed out that on the trending page we have Logan Paul and the second trending one was "Man of the woods"
Everyone is just click baiting
*chuckles*
These days they can't help themselves, Logan Paul. That's Jon Tron. Please.
Logan stop it!
Stop reacting to all the bad memes! The "Sayonara Zetsubou Sensei" Logan Paul? Really? Now
I'm gonna have to put my foot down and say
I am officially
challenging you in a battle. Now the beautifulness of the Logan Paul meme is that the moral high ground of the meme
It's not making fun of suicide. It's making fun of how stupid Logan Paul is. I'm gonna rate this meme
7 and a half
logan paul: did we just find a dead person in the suicide forest
It's... It's a meme where everyone can just get on board
Logan Paul fan or not. Everyone likes to laugh at a stupid thing.
Oh! Look he make a mistake?
Good thing i never make any of those. I'm
I'm fearful that the meme will run out fast
It's gonna burn out fast. I better get this video up A.S.P
But I think in a couple months from now on we'll still see the Logan Paul *weird noise*
Face appearing somewhere else that's sort of relatable
Maybe maybe we'll turn into a nice little crossover meme in the future. The future will tell us all about this.
Now we have time for one more meme. Can I get a...
BONUS MEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEME
BONUS MEME
Lucky you. We have time for a bonus meme.
This means
Special... time for everyone. It's the okay sign meme. I don't get this meme. At all.
I don't get it. We never played this game when I was young but apparently if you do the upside-down
errrrrrrr
Hand sign and you make them look at it you're supposed to catch them off-guard like "Hey, buddy. Look at this!"
You get to punch them. it's called the circle game. what the heck is what is this?
What is I don't understand? It's just kind of annoying. Let's play the circle game, sucker. nice little meme generator
Dotnet here. I'm rating this meme a 0. That's right, the first 0 on meme review
I hate this meme  it's so stupid
I hate it so much. "Ever notice that
Italy is shaped like a bo..."
GOD DAMN IT
AHHHHH